what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime opera and today i will be
breaking down the latest twist
in the seven deadly sins sequel a twist
that completely shocked
all of us long time seven deadly sins
fans
arthur and merlin were recently revealed
to be the villains of the seven deadly
sins sequel
and in the latest chapter we finally got
some information about how they might
have turned
into villains in fact arthur just
implied that he plans to eliminate
the remaining members of the seven
deadly sins
along with the four nights of the
apocalypse which is absolutely
crazy so let's get into it if you
enjoyed the seven deadly sins and four
nights of the apocalypse content
on this channel and you want to see more
you know what to do just leave a quick
like and comment
it only takes a second but it helps with
the youtube algorithm
and if you're new to anime uproar or
maybe watch our videos but you haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications remember you have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting the
option that says all
if you don't do all of those things
you're still gonna miss a ton of our
videos even if you are subscribed it's
just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram
at animeopror finally this video will of
course contain seven deadly sins sequel
spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned
the latest chapter picks up inside the
throne room in camelot
where arthur is still berating ironside
for failing to complete his mission
arthur is determined to destroy leonis
for some reason
and he is disappointed that ironside
couldn't even defeat a child
even if that child happens to be one of
the four knights of the apocalypse
arthur then proceeds to use a terrifying
display of chaos power
to pierce into ironside's flesh and
practically tear him a limb from limb
this is a scene straight out of the most
terrifying horror movies
and man i have to say that chaos power
is the stuff of nightmares
i can't even show most of this stuff on
youtube it is that gruesome
as he mercilessly tortures ironside
arthur is ironically talking about how
camelot is a land with no pain and
no sadness a land where no one is
exposed to any kind of threat
or calamity uh what how are you saying
this while brutally torturing one of
your own men
this is just insane but if you thought
that was crazy
arthur then goes on to say something
even crazier he says that as long as the
remnants of the seven deadly sins
and the four knights of the apocalypse
are still around camelot
will never have true peace this implies
that arthur is going to try to take down
the remaining members of the seven
deadly sins
along with the four knights of the
apocalypse merlin appears to be on
arthur's side and escanor is
unfortunately no longer with us but that
still leaves
bonn gother king the end and of course
meliodas
as arthur's targets as crazy as arthur's
animosity towards the seven deadly sins
sounds to all of us who were fans of the
original series this is also an exciting
development for me personally because it
means that we might be seeing the
remaining five sins
in this sequel sooner than we thought if
arthur is the current main villain of
the story and he is targeting the seven
deadly sins along with the four knights
of the apocalypse
then it's safe to assume that we'll be
hearing from the seven deadly sins gang
sooner rather than later arthur says
that we must protect mankind from the
constant holy wars that have been taking
place
among the various races implying that he
is not necessarily interested in peace
between the different races
he seems interested in protecting and
freeing the humans in particular
and he isn't concerned about the
well-being of the other races
he is also determined to protect camelot
but camelot now appears to be located in
a completely different realm
from the rest of britannia it is as if
the giant palace of camelot
exists inside some sort of pocket
dimension created by chaos power
at the end of the original series arthur
set out to turn camelot
into an everlasting kingdom so perhaps
placing camelot
inside some sort of chaos realm is part
of arthur's plan
to make his kingdom eternal at any rate
arthur eventually decides to stop
torturing ironside and once ironside is
released his wounds are suddenly
completely healed and even the blood
that had spilled all over him is now
gone
arthur looks at ironside and laughs
telling ironside that hey
at least the torture took out all the
poison from your blood
and in that moment arthur looks like the
kind and friendly person that he
had been in the original series which to
be honest is even scarier than if he was
just completely evil
all of the time what is going on with
this man did chaos power drive him crazy
can't merlin help him in some way
ironside vows to successfully defeat
percival next time around
but arthur tells ironside that he has a
different mission
for him instead of fighting the four
knights of the apocalypse ironside's job
will be to search for arthur's
bride um okay ironside is clearly
surprised by this request from arthur
and i think
all of us readers are as well after all
of these crazy reveals
including the fact that arthur is a
villain that he is targeting the
remaining seven deadly sins and that he
seems to be trying to protect humans at
the expense of the
other races i don't think that any of us
were expecting arthur to just casually
ask
ironside to find him a wife also merlin
is
right there bro she's right there
meanwhile as i said merlin is present
throughout this entire scene but she
doesn't seem to actually say
anything she is too quiet suspiciously
quiet
i get the strong feeling that she
doesn't support what's happening with
arthur and she doesn't agree
with his actions but for some reason she
has to go along with them we have no
idea what
that reason is and that makes this whole
situation
all the more mysterious the focus of the
chapter then switches back to sistana
and the aftermath of the battle against
ironside
anne's father thanks percival and the
gang for protecting sustana
even though there is a lot of physical
damage to the town thankfully none of
the citizens
died as a result of the battle and that
is the most important thing
sin is once again asked about his ally
or allies and where they went
but he is dodgy and he refuses to answer
this is getting pretty frustrating to me
personally because i was expecting a big
bond reveal but i guess we'll have to
wait a bit longer
anne's father then explains that he is
well acquainted with ironside
and percival's grandpa because they
served camelot as holy knights
alongside anne's mother in the image
that we see of anne's mother with
ironside and percival's grandpa
in the background we can also see arthur
merlin and
nanashi that samurai guy who appeared in
the original seven deadly sins series
during the visel festival
arc it seems that nanashi decided to
serve king arthur in camelot
after the original series ended nanashi
is a pretty random character to just
like throw in there but
personally i do appreciate every
reference to the original series so it's
all good with me now the weird thing
is anne's mother had once described
ironside
as a noble and upright man who was
always striving to do
good so clearly something has changed
drastically with ironside
in the past 16 years and that very much
echoes
arthur's own transformation from
kind-hearted hero
and ally of the sins to a villain king
who apparently wants to destroy the
seven deadly sins
roughly 16 years ago some major event
must have occurred in camelot
something that completely changed not
only king arthur but also many of his
men
including ironside did the power of
chaos suddenly take control of arthur
and corrupt his mind
did some impostor manage to somehow take
control of arthur did something else
happen to genuinely change arthur's mind
about the seven deadly sins and the holy
wars i'm betting that the power of chaos
will prove to be the key to
understanding what really happened
but we'll have to wait and see how
things play out the chapter ends as anne
decides to leave systana
and join percival sin and nacienza and
dani on their journey
and dreams of becoming a great holy
night one day just like her mother
but the fight with ironside has taught
her that she still has a long way to go
so ann is going to set off from sistana
and begin
more intense training and since percival
and the squad
are already there it makes sense for
them all to travel together
so after a tearful goodbye with her
father and joins the squad
and the adventure continues personally i
really like anne i think she's cool and
very badass
and i think she will make a good
addition to the squad her name
anne galahad is likely a reference to
sir galahad
one of the knights of the round table in
arthurian legend
so it makes sense that anne would play
an important part in the story
that said as much as i do like the
current squad
i definitely want to see tristan and
lancelot making their appearance
sometime soon not to mention the ogs
like bonn and meliodas
let me know what you guys think why
would arthur turn against
the seven deadly sins and does the fact
that he directly mentioned them as his
targets
mean that some of them are about to
return to the story sooner
rather than later also what's the deal
with ironside
how did he go from a noble knight who
does only good things to an evil villain
who murdered his own father
tried to murder his son and nearly
sacrificed an
entire town finally when is the main
squad going to meet up with the other
knights of the apocalypse definitely
share your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more summer daily sins and four nights
of the apocalypse videos here on the
channel
please leave that like and comment it
only takes a second but it helps a lot
then if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor make this the video that
you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our
anime uproar patrons for making videos
like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma he is
an absolute mad lad
and disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa
al-jatal hirokami and water the toasted
chi the spike
emperor otaku spidey life chanel
tungsten tarkis baked buddhist cody
hebert and monkey d
quilly finally thank you also to our pro
hero tier patrons including the one and
only gilgamesh the red haired raven
angel crews
rathune de ora very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks joanne garcia techno ted
fat boy games corey mcgowan and soul ray
slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos
along with these legendary people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you